not for us while we're in the same shirt
as I am on the previous vlog it's
because I didn't realize it and I just
what's a [ __ ] shirt anyways who cares
all right don't judge me remember this
petty shirt remember this one yeah you
liked it Oh what's coming in your face
yeah now grown up if you didn't know I
was broke I was a little girl child that
didn't have much but I always knew that
I had more than enough but whatever I
didn't think I was poor I always had my
Asian parents to remind me exactly how
poor I was blessed an amazing your life
is it a lot of American sitcom [ __ ] real
Asian parents always like to remind you
how broke they are even if they have
money
mommies Jordans okay for 14 [ __ ]
Moses do the [ __ ] god damn but if you
wanna find out if general and you're
broke you got to do the McDonald scale
of ghetto promise number one you know
you're ghetto based on your McDonald's
menu and a kid when you go to McDonald's
and you didn't even know they had more
than two things on the menu you broke it
but before I had a job I thought
mcdonnell's only had two burgers the
dollar bit chicken and the dollar double
cheeseburger and if you got anything
else you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] because of
my financial sense that was what you
call a broke-ass hater you have a look
at people who got a combo meal like they
were better than you is [ __ ] just me
no look at this [ __ ] supersize
in this prime money night forward you
don't win a filet-o-fish [ __ ] you rich
we all know it's all about economy baby
my supersize a drink when you can go eat
inside get a smugly and reveal that
[ __ ] that's right quench your thirst
[ __ ] on supersize my meal i supersize
my life you know you'll get out based on
how you reacted to the $5 20 piece
McNuggets if you react like this when he
keeps McNuggets that's an amazing deal
oh you rich and if you react like this
you call it oh [ __ ]
when they change the price of chicken
nugget the jet tub erupted I'm talking
about I ate so many McNuggets I started
to look like it was so funny because the
way people went about it you would have
thought the cure to aids wasn't one of
those damn things have a McNugget it's
gone and a brooch our chicken notice was
something that you never really got
unless you really wanted him or there
was a [ __ ] deal they were too
expensive and amount that you could
afford didn't really get you full of
that [ __ ] wasn't rich people [ __ ] 20
pieces for five dollars
small children pregnant women all that
[ __ ] ladies y'all we're all in danger
if you got the way of me and my meeting
of it no we call that we call that a
Mick rampage you know you'll get old
based on how you react every time the
McRib comes back and this is you the
[ __ ] the McRib is back the [ __ ] what
about the kids
is this the McRib always toys with the
fat man's emotions because of the way
they market that delicious sandwich it's
because your kid get to get away and
your king take it back if y'all ever
notice the McRib in the fast food
industry is like jay-z the hip hop they
say you're leaving the game but you're
keep [ __ ] coming back that muhfucka
jay-z said he was going with time 26
times but every time he confesses a new
album this is it I'm done you got it was
always I'm backed over this is it for
real
I'm done it's your boy I'm baked what
y'all think that was done [ __ ] because
you said you were Oh what is going on
YouTube thank you for tuning in again
yes yes you guys realize
got the one two three left to get it
let's go I got tired of it I wanna move
on I don't need anymore
maybe I'll bring it back maybe I'll well
I don't know I'm kind of tired of doing
this like they set structure stuff I
just want to put up whatever I [ __ ] I'm
on and hopefully that's like if you
don't [ __ ] yourself but yes if you guys
realize the last two comments were on
sale for a little bit cheaper just for
you guys but of course
boom release our new designs those sales
will disappear so copy it while you can
buy this a little bit cheaper you know
just for you know say a little bucks
thank you guys for tuning in and yes
triple F we'll be back coming up this
Wednesday so I will see y'all pen I love
y'all [ __ ] maybe I should bring
this shirt back you like this one depend
on one I don't know it's a old me maybe
retro retro golfer Bronco I was a little
child that didn't have much but I never
better day and you didn't even know they
had more than two things on the menu I
know but the manual when they had the
mango